The SCP Foundation has dealt with plenty of
things that no one could ever even imagine,
creatures and objects beyond anyone’s wildest
dreams.
An evil old man that can walk through walls,
an Ikea that never ends, a giant underwater
eel that can erase your memories, and so much
more.
But sometimes, the anomalies they discover
seem to be plucked from a familiar nightmare.
In Korea, shortly after the end of the Second
World War, a team of SCP Foundation officers
encountered something right out of a dark,
twisted fairytale.
In the late 1940s, the fifth squad of the
Eastern Division of the SCP Foundation, received
a call to come to Busan, Korea, and investigate
a potential anomaly involving several deaths.
Three agents, referred to from now on as Agent
One, Agent Two, and Agent Three, were deployed
to the region, where they first headed to
the morgue to examine the bodies under the
cover of reporters investigating the deaths.
The nature of the wounds indicated an animal
attack.
An eyewitness account from an old woman who
saw a fox-like creature eating one of her
cows supported this hypothesis.
Of course, the agents knew differently.
Sure, it was something like an animal, but
this culprit was no animal they had ever encountered.
The three recounted stories of fox spirits,
villainous tricksters, capable of changing
their shape and oppressing all kinds of havoc
on those unfortunate souls they targeted.
While sweeping the area, the agents encountered
a beautiful young woman sitting under a waterfall,
combing her hair.
She was dressed in a light robe, and her feet
were bare.
This, they noticed, gave her away.
Instead of having human feet, she had paws
covered in reddish fur.
The agents assumed that this creature was
inexperienced, unable to properly conceal
herself.
They believed they had the upper hand on her.
They would soon see the error of their ways.
The woman greeted the three men and invited
them to have dinner at her nearby cottage.
Believing themselves to be relatively safe,
armed as they were and with three people against
one delicate - if inhuman - woman, they agreed.
The fox woman ushered them to a lovely, rustic
cottage and sat them down at the dining table.
She served them plum wine, rice, pickled turnips,
and meat.
Everything was delicious, and, feeling at
ease, the agents decided to turn in for the
night.
This creature, though unusual, did not seem
threatening.
She had no reason to attack them, or so they
thought.
Agent One woke in the night to go to the bathroom
and tiptoed out of the cottage to relieve
himself behind a bush.
There, he saw Agent Two with the fox woman.
Let’s just say…they were getting to know
each other intimately.
Suddenly, in an abrupt change of mood, she
bit him.
She tore the man’s throat out with her teeth
before he could scream, turning his cries
to a wet, useless gurgle.
Then, she took her hand and plunged it into
his belly, shredding the flesh with razor-sharp
claws.
He thrashed and tried to fight her off, but
she shoved him to the ground and tore his
stomach open, rooting around inside for something.
When she found it, she stopped and gleefully
tore out his liver.
As the first agent looked on in horror, she
lifted his colleague’s liver and swallowed
it whole in one single gulp.
Not noticing her onlooker, she continued her
vile work, peeling her victim’s skin like
an orange.
The agent who witnessed the whole thing regained
his ability to move, adrenaline flooding his
veins, and ran back to the cottage in search
of his remaining teammate.
Agent One shook Agent Three awake, babbling
incoherently as he tried to explain what was
going on, and the fact that they needed to
leave and they needed to leave now.
To his shock, Agent Two walked into the room,
asking what all the noise was about.
Agent One immediately noticed the man’s
glowing yellow eyes and made his next move
without thinking.
He pulled out his gun and fired.
Agent Three drew his weapon next, pointing
it at One and yelling for him to put the weapon
away.
One tried to explain that this man was not
their friend, but rather the fox in disguise,
but he wouldn’t listen.
The fox grabbed One, and Three shot him in
the upper arm.
Agent One dropped to the ground, wailing in
pain, as the fox laughed in a high-pitched
devilish whine.
Agent One scrambled away, crawling into the
living room and slamming the rice paper-screened
door shut.
There, laid out on the dining table, was another
agent.
They had seen this man at the base of the
mountain only a few days ago, but now, here
he was, eyes wide and glassy and skin flayed
open.
Then, Agent One saw the remains of their dinner.
In the bowls, there was the flesh of their
fallen colleague.
With it was not rice, but maggots, crawling
over the meat.
Agent One was able to improvise a weapon,
breaking off a portion of a wooden beam and
stabbing the fox through the stomach as she
lunged through the rice paper door.
He made his way through the forest, running
as fast as he could with his gunshot wound.
He found his way to the bank of the river
and attempted to cross.
However, he was disoriented and afraid, it
was pitch black outside, and he was nauseous
from the pain.
He slipped on the wet rocks, and hit his head,
falling into the water.
The rapids carried him away, pulling him downstream
for half a mile before he was able to grab
hold of an exposed branch.
Agent One made his way back to his team’s
van, broke a window, and pulled a flamethrower
from the back.
He recalled legends about similar fox-like
creatures mentioning an aversion to fire,
and so he prepared to fight her off with as
much as he could get.
Just as he readied the flamethrower for use,
the fox woman emerged from the tree line.
What happened next is unknown, lost from the
official record.
However, after several days, a retrieval team
tracked down Agent One and rescued him, capturing
the fox woman in the process.
He was taken to the hospital, where he remained
with a serious infection for several days
before he was discharged.
Initially, the Foundation planned to terminate
the creature.
However, Agent One vehemently opposed that
decision.
He insisted that they should keep her alive.
He also recommended the containment methods
used to imprison her be adjusted.
The Agent promised that she would not be held
by the chosen methods and that the result
of her inevitable escape would be devastating.
In his official interview, he had this to
say on the subject: “Like I said, she's
spiteful.
Every little slight in her eyes she saves
up, and the only way she knows how to repay
an insult is death.
Chaining her to the wall like an animal…
when she gets out, and she will get out, she's
going to kill everyone who had the slightest
thing to do with it.
She won't settle for anything else.”
Much to the Foundation’s surprise, Agent
One visited the fox woman in her holding cell
several times.
The Foundation attempted to understand this
concerning behavior, but Agent One refused
to admit that there was anything strange about
it.
His attachment to the fox woman had been attributed
to Stockholm Syndrome, brought on as a result
of several days in the woods spent as her
captive.
To this day, Agent One is the only person
to survive that long alone with the creature
that is now known as SCP-953.
SCP-953 is a female red fox, weighing approximately
8 kg.
Unlike an ordinary fox, her spine splits at
the base into nine different tails.
Previously referred to as a kitsune, the shapeshifting
fox spirit of Japanese legend, it has since
been discovered that she is actually a kumiho,
a Korean fox spirit with similar qualities.
SCP-953 is a polymorph, also known as a shapeshifter,
though she retains some aspects of her fox-like
appearance no matter what form she is in,
including ears, paws, tails, eyes, and fur.
Though she attempts to cover these revealing
physical traits with clothes and hairstyling,
she is unable to get rid of them entirely.
In addition to her shapeshifting, 953 has
potent psychic abilities including the powers
of suggestion and telepathy.
She has used these abilities to wreak havoc
on her victims, causing them to experience
terrifying hallucinations, hurt themselves,
and, in one particularly horrific case, convincing
a mother to kill, cook, and eat her own child.
She has also successfully used these abilities
to escape containment six times.
SCP-953’s most recent escape caused the
deaths of ten Foundation staff.
After destroying nearby security cameras,
she shifted into the appearance of an adult
man, walking out the front door in a stolen
lab coat.
Anyone who stopped her to ask for identification
was swiftly slaughtered.
After her escape, the fox disappeared for
five years until she resurfaced at Yiffcon,
a convention for furries and anthropomorphic
animal enthusiasts.
There, the fox-like ears and tail that might
draw attention in other places allowed her
to hide in plain sight.
The Foundation was alerted to her presence
when a terrified hotel housekeeper called
911, after walking in on SCP-953 slicing open
the torso of a dead convention-goer.
By the time the Foundation reached the convention
center and captured the fox, she had left
two dozen corpses in her wake.
The bodies, all mutilated almost beyond recognition,
were found scattered throughout the hotel
in various places, including: stuffed into
a mattress, hanging over a shower curtain
rod, rolled up in a carpet, and strewn across
a banquet table.
The survivors were given Class-A Amnestics
to wipe their memories, and released from
custody.
The convention was cut short, with a dangerous
gas leak as the cover story.
So far, the fox has not escaped Foundation
custody again.
SCP-953 is kept in a Type 4 containment cell
in Hallway 99 of Site-17.
She is provided 1.5 kg of fresh liver every
day to eat, as well as clean drinking water
and a futon with blankets and sheets that
are changed out weekly.
In exchange for good behavior, she is provided
the occasional luxury item such as plum wine,
novels, or a variety of Korean sweets.
After so many successful escapes, the Foundation
realized that simple physical containment
was not adequate to keep SCP-953 away from
the general population.
Making use of her fear of dogs, the Foundation
keeps 953’s containment chamber surrounded
by dog kennels filled with Korean Jindo and
American Foxhounds.
All staff assigned to SCP-953’s containment
chamber are to be given background checks,
looking for any prior ties to the furry community.
Such affiliations may make them vulnerable
to SCP-953’s influence, and have been attributed
to the death of one Agent Gallagher.
Because of her psychic abilities, no direct
contact with 953 is allowed.
All communication with the fox must take place
from a distance of 100 meters, and food, water,
and other items are delivered to her via a
robotic assistant.
She must be considered armed and dangerous
at all times and can only be transported while
accompanied by six members of armed personnel.
There are folklore-based procedures in place
for employees as well, providing specific
instructions to staff assigned to SCP-953.
No matter how odd or ridiculous these instructions
may seem, the staff is to adhere to them and
remember that what we might think of as classic
fairytales are often more like ancient Special
Containment Procedures.
If versions of the kumiho and the kitsune
exist, then who knows what other seemingly
mythical creatures the SCP Foundation might
encounter in the future?
What other beasts are lurking on the edges
of civilization, hiding in the shadows, or
worse, hiding in plain sight just under our
noses?
Best to brush up on your local folklore, just
in case, and be careful out there.
Now go check out “SCP-3663 - TUNNEL MONSTER”
and “SCP-2430 - Immortal Hitler Clone”
for more haunting anomalous humanoids!